did i tell the story about how my  brother and sister  joey and sheila had a car that they  were joey and sheila come on we got them  all  um it's a big family what kind of names  you need um  i got a peter um they're all like irish  catholics like  they're all bible names man there's a  [ __ ] marriage yeah  joey chile had a car that they split and  the deal was  whoever was in the car when it  like broke what like needed a repair  you had to pay for it so they would just  change dude  right so they would just like push it  into the driveway  smoking and be like and then the next  morning be like it was fine for me  um that's the kind of family guys that's  where i that's  where i live that's my origin story